>>
SWANSON: Hi, I'm here with Google I/O Sometrics.
Could you please tell me a little bit about
yourself and what you do?
>> SWANSON: Yeah, no problem. I'm Ian Swanson,
I'm one of co-founders and CEO of Sometrics.
Sometrics--we built products which helps,
you know, social application publishers, monetizers
and understand their audience.
>> Great, so what did you (INDISTINCT)? Do
you Google pick us?
>> Yeah, so we--we definitely utilize OpenSocial
as we work with many publishers that are on
MySpace or High Five, in Orkett (ph). We work
with 2,200 application development companies
and so we definitely utilize OpenSocial.
>> SWANSON: Who was the reason behind the
utilizing OpenSocial?
>> Well, it was nice to have a standard. I
mean, we’re making--we have an analytics
product, an ad manager product, as well a
virtual currency economy solution. And to
build those for each one of the different
social APIs that are out there is very difficult.
So it’s good to--to build it off of OpenSocial
and build to make it so they can scale across
multiple platforms.
>> SWANSON: Do you have any tips and tricks
about the developers who are (INDISTINCT)
OpenSocial.
>> So Sometrics has been around for the past
three years and as soon as OpenSocial came
out, we quickly adopted it. And I think what
key is just staying up on all the latest news
and tips, to utilize the Google Blogs that
are out there, and I think that’s something
that a lot of developers really don’t utilize
as a resource. And so, we just try to keep
updated on all the latest news.
>> SWANSON: Are there any products that you
offer (INDISTINCT)?
>> Yes, we have three. We have an Analytics
Suite, we have an Ad Server, as well as Virtual
Economy Platform. All three of the products,
they help the developer understand who there
audience is that uses their game, whether
it’s like a MySpace poker game, as well
as how they serve ads and how to make money
from those users. So our products have big-end
social targeting, and then it’s very easy
plug-and-play using OpenSocial.
>> SWANSON: So how will developers make money
using your products?
>> Yup. So from Ad serving level, let’s
say an advertiser like Nike or AT&T contacts
application developer and let’s say we want
to reach males 18 to 25, they build to use
Sometrics as an ad server, build and target
those males and very easily deliver that ad
campaign. And from a virtual currency some
point, we have solution where some of them
signs up for netflix and they can then earn
points or poker chips, in this example, to
keep playing their MySpace poker game.
>> SWANSON: Got it. Is there anything else
you’d like to add?
>> Well, I think it’s really important that
Google has been making the standards in OpenSocial
particularly where it’s very easy for developers
to, you know, make a product, make a scale
across multiple platforms. And there’s a
lot of companies like Sometrics out there
that have a tool set that layer on top from
a utility perspective. And I think it’s
crucial for any publisher to really understand
who that audience is and how do we make a--how
do we make a dollar at the end of the day,
and that’s where Sometrics comes in.
>> SWANSON: Thank you for your time.
>> Thank you, I appreciate it.